Well let's start by thinking about position 3.
When the mass is way back here as far away from equilibrium as it's going to go
it has only potential energy.
All the energy is stored in the spring for an instant the block stops moving
before it changes direction making the kinetic energy 0.
Let's turn to position 1 next where here the spring isn't stretched out.
It's at equilibrium. X is 0, so there can be any potential energy.
So what happened to all the potential energy that was storing the spring back here?
Well, it must've been converted to kinetic energy.
At position 2, midway between positions 1 and 3,
I know the spring is stretched somewhat so it has potential energy
but it's not as stretched as much as it was at position 3.
So some of that potential energy must've also been converted
to the energy of motion, kinetic energy. So these are the answers.